Hello good morning everyone, my name is Saurangshu Bhattacharya, I am a faculty member at the
computer science and engineering department in IIT Kharagpur and today I am going to discuss
foundations of neural networks and deep learning.
So let us go with the discussion, so yeah so just to highlight the topic once more,
we are going to discuss today foundations of neural networks and deep learning, okay.
So I think most of you would have heard about a neural network.
So what is a neural network?
A neural network is a computation model, so what is a computation model?
It is a particular way of performing a computation, okay, so it is a computation model inspired
by the structure and function of biological networks, okay.
So what do we mean by this?
So a neural network tries to emulate the process by which our brain or the human brain performs
computation, so as we know it does perform computations in order to do various tasks.
So for example in order to do perception tasks like visual perception or sensory perception
or auditory perception etc., so sound, you know senses, then sight, the visual perception
all these things, okay.
All these things are performed by the neural networks in our brain and elsewhere in our
body through a particular computational mechanism, okay.
And what we are going to discuss today is a particular computational mechanism which
emulates this process.
So it is not exactly same as our brain but it tries to emulate the same process, okay.
Now the important thing to notice here is that this is also very very different from
traditional computation model which is more logic based, okay.
So it is temporal logic based, so in your program when you write program, you write
them, so one logical step at a time, okay.
Here also there are logical steps but the more important or the more I would say the
more the predominant aspect of this neural network is that it is massively parallel.
So there are many many parallel computations which are going on which create a neural network.
So we will go into the details of that in a minute, okay.
So what is a neural network, okay.
So a neural network is a directed acyclic graph of something called neurons, okay.
So building so here you can see the structure of a neural network, each of these circles
are what are called neurons, okay.
So neurons are the basic building blocks of a neural network, okay.
And now what happens and to tell you this each neuron is a very simple performs a very
simple computation or is a very simple function, okay.
Now these neurons are connected in a graph in a certain structure and that structure
is called directed acyclic graph, okay.
So what is a directed acyclic graph?
A directed acyclic graph is a graph, so I am assuming all of you know what is a graph.
So a graph has nodes, so in this particular case the neurons are going to be the nodes
of the directed acyclic graph and a graph has edges or links, okay between different
nodes, okay.
And these nodes, these links in case of a neural network are going to be directed links
something like this, okay.
Now these directed links and nodes, so the nodes are connected by directed links and
these directed links are connected in a manner such that there is no cycle, okay.
So no cycle in the graph or to be specific there is no directed cycle.
So for example, this is not a valid neural network, so this kind of a graph is not a
valid neural network, okay.
So with this we know what is a neural network.
Now what happens, okay.
So a neural network takes a vector of data as input and produces one or more output.
So I told you one particular view of a neural network.
So let us see, so a neural network takes a vector of data as input, okay.
So what does this mean, this means that I can now say that a neural network takes as
input x, okay.
So what is x?
This is x, okay, this is the input x, okay.
It is a vector.
So here you have three values as input x1, x2 and x3, okay.
So x is equal to x1, x2 and x3, okay and it produces an output, let us call it y, okay.
y here there are two outputs y1 and y2, okay.
So another way of thinking about a neural network is it is a function approximator f,
y is equal to f of x, okay.
So this is another way of thinking about a neural network, okay, that each neural network
takes some input x, okay and produces an output y, okay.
Now these outputs depends on something called weights of the neural network, weights are
attached to the link, okay.
We will come to this in a minute when we go into these, okay.
And the important thing is that these weights can be learned, okay.
We will see what that means in a minute, okay.
Okay, so I gave you a very high level overview of a neural network, neural network, two ways
of thinking about it.
First is it is a network of neurons very similar to what our brain has, other way of thinking
about it is it is a function approximator y is equal to f of x, okay.
Now question is what is deep learning, okay.
So deep learning is nothing but learning with neural networks, but it is it has a specific
property that so there is no hard and fast difference between neural network and deep
learning.
The only difference is that the depth of the neural network that you use in deep learning
is very high.
Now what is depth?
So in this case you see the neurons are arranged in layers.
We will come to that in a minute, but you can think of this as the first layer of neurons,
this as the second layer of neurons and this as the third layer of neurons, okay.
So here the depth will be 2.
So actually if this is only input then you do not count, so this the input layer you
can count as 0.
So the output layer here is 2.
So the depth of this neural network is 2, okay.
So the number of layers that you have one after the other in the neural network is called
depth and we will see in a minute why this depth parameter is so important.
And after the advent of this deep learning paradigm, so neural networks have been around
for a long time, we will get into the history in a minute, okay.
But after the advent of this deep learning paradigm, it has revolutionized the field
of machine learning and also made neural networks more, much more popular than it used to be
earlier, okay.
So now that I have given you a basic introduction, let me give you a brief overview of how this
field of neural network developed, okay.
So the first important paper is by McCulloch and Pitts, it was published in 1943 and the
paper is called a logical model of the brain function, okay.
So this gave, so at the time people were studying neurons, so this is in neuroscience community
and people were studying how our brain performs this computation and so McCulloch and Pitts
came up with a logical model of the neuron like a math, so here you can think of this
logical as a mathematical model of the brain function which we will discuss in a bit, okay.
So this is the first thing that there was a mathematical model of a single neuron, okay.
Then came the perceptron model, okay, this came in 1962, this perceptron model was the
first application of this neural network model you can say to a particular learning task,
okay.
So we will discuss this, at the around the same time there were many competing things,
so along with perceptron there was this Adeline which is the adaptive linear model, okay.
So all these were becoming very, very popular and people were getting very, very excited
that you know neural networks will basically replace standard computer programming and then
I mean we will be able to simulate the brain and do whatever the brain can do, okay.
Now this particular paper by Minsky and paper showed that actually this kind of linear model
perceptron or Adeline, they cannot approximate many, many different functions, okay.
So for example, they cannot even approximate a simple ZOR function, okay.
And you can say this is like, you can say this caused what is called AI winter, okay.
It is called AI winter which is that, that people were very excited about this neural
network model and then they figured out no, it is actually not that good, okay.
Now parallelly around 6770, these two papers they started talking about multi-layer perceptron,
okay.
So the problem with single layer perceptron is that it is a very limited computation
model, okay.
So it can only approximate very few functions, okay.
But multi-layer perceptrons can approximate many, many different functions, okay.
But the problem is how to learn the weights of a multi-layer perceptron and for that even
today we use this algorithm called the back propagation algorithm we will see what it is,
okay.
So these ideas started coming in around 1950 and basically the whole thing sort of materialized
in this nature paper by Rumelhardt, Hinton and William in 1986.
So this is basically the time when neural networks were formally established as a good
model for learning, okay.
Now this continues so and people were using after this people, so this is also sometimes
called the second AI boom, okay.
And people started using neural networks to train many, many different models around this
time, okay but one of the main problem was that people very soon realized that the amount
of data available for us and the amount of computational power available for us is not
good enough to you know solve real world problem, okay.
So then people started looking at other models like support vector machines, etc. which were
much more efficient both computation wise and also data wise, okay.
So that caused you can say something like the second AI winter which is that for using
the technology of that time we could not train neural networks which were sufficiently useful,
okay.
And then came the use of GPUs and also the compute and storage all this became much,
much faster and this third AI revolution which is the deep learning revolution started around
2013 and the final like it was already very, very popular in 2015 you with this 2015 paper
which is by Benjiro, Lekun and Hinton which is called the deep learning paper in it, okay.
So this is the brief history of how neural networks became the popular model that they
are today, okay.
So furthermore let us, so these are the two diagrams I have taken from this deep learning
paper, the initial deep learning paper, I think deep learning book, yeah.
And so if you see this shows the history of, so on the left it shows the history of the
data sets available, okay, so initially you had data sets, so here if you see the y axis
is the number of examples and it is in log scale.
So around 50s, 60s, till about 80s most of the data sets that you had were only few thousand.
So if you see it is 10 to the power 3 to 10 to the power 4 data sets, right, so this is
around this area, okay.
And then suddenly around 2000 there was a big after, just after 2000, so around maybe
2005, 2006 as the compute power started increasing dramatically, the size of the data sets started
increasing dramatically and you see in this small amount of time there is an order of
magnitude increase in the number of training data points, okay.
So some of the very popular data sets like ImageNet, okay, very, very big data sets and
then ImageNet 10K came and the WMT data set which is a machine translation data set which
has 10 to the power 9 examples and so on and so forth, all these data sets came, okay.
So this large amount of data was one of the reasons or one of the necessary conditions
for this revolution, why is that?
The reason is that initially the traditional ML models performance on these, so these data
sets were not only large, they were also extremely complex data sets, so the tasks were extremely
complex and we realized that existing machine learning models were not able to perform very
well on these data sets, okay.
There was data, there was data as you know in machine learning gives us the information
to learn, okay.
So there is information in the data but we are not able to learn all that information,
okay.
So this is the first thing.
The second thing here is on the right hand side what we are showing is the size of different
models that we could train as a function of time, okay.
So you see, so this is a little bit old because it is showing mostly till 2015.
Now as you know, we can train, I mean anything between 70 billion parameter to much more
than that, okay.
Here we are just showing connections per neuron.
So what you can think is that the number of parameters will probably be like 2, 3 orders
of magnitude more than this, okay.
So already again you can see as the data set became more and more difficult, the models
also became higher and higher number of parameters.
So here you can see already we are talking about 6, 7 which are 10 to the power 3 connections
per neuron.
So each neuron is connected to thousand other neurons, okay.
This means that basically you will have probably around maybe like a million or like 500,000
parameter something like that, okay.
Then this one is this unsupervised convolutional neural network, okay.
And this has like, yeah, probably something like, yeah, so maybe 10 million parameter.
And nowadays if you see some of the foundation models, they have at least like the minimum
ones are start from something like 7 billion parameter, okay.
Maybe slightly smaller but yeah, and we do not even know how many parameters are there
for example in the GPT model, okay.
So this is the timeline of change of how the different model sizes evolved, okay.
And how the different data set sizes evolved, okay.
And you can see there is a connection between them, okay.
The third important thing is on the left side, bottom left, which is development of certain
software.
So there was the basic Torch software which was in 2002.
Then there was the Tiano which is a Python based software which is 2007.
Then there was TensorFlow and then there was PyTorch, okay.
So around 2015, 2016, we have the most popular framework that we use today, okay.
So this also led to the deep learning revolution which is that everybody started using these
deep learning models, okay.
So this is the third most important parameter.
And the reason is that firstly, they helped us use GPU and secondly, they made defining
and training neural networks very, very easy.
So for example, the back propagation algorithm was built in into the software, okay.
So let us go ahead and see how this whole ecosystem works, okay.
So we have already discussed this.
So what is a neuron?
Neuron is a basic processing unit of a neural network.
Each neuron has some input, okay.
So typically it will be written as a vector x.
So this is the input to a neuron.
Now each neuron also has this weight.
So there are these directed edges which are coming from other inputs or other neurons.
So these are the directed edges.
Along each directed edge of a neuron, there is a weight w, okay.
So if there are three inputs, there are three incoming edges to the neuron and for each
of these incoming edges, there is a weight, okay.
And there is a bias value b for each neuron, okay.
Now what happens at the neuron?
So the neuron performs what is called this kind of a computation.
So what is this computation?
It first computes the weighted sum of the input, okay.
So if xi's are the input and wi's are the, so let me just write this.
So if xi's are the input and wi's are the corresponding weight, then what we will do
is we compute sum over i.
So in this case i is equal to 1, 2, 3 wi xi.
Then we add the bias b to this, okay.
And then we pass it through this activation function called s, okay.
Sometimes denoted as x, sometimes denoted as sigma, okay.
So this activation function is actually represented here, okay and then it produces a single output
which is oi.
So the output is o.
So by the way, here the neuron produces a single output, okay, okay.
So yeah, so I think this is clear.
So this is the computation model of a neuron, this is also called the Maculagin-Pitts model,
okay.
So this is the 1943 paper that we were talking about, okay.
Now what is this activation function and what is the need for this activation function?
So you see in the previous, so let me come back here.
So how can I write this?
So I can write this particular transformation.
So for the time being if I ignore the b, I can simply write this transformation as w
transpose x, okay.
Both w and x are vectors here, right.
So I am now denoting the weights and the inputs as vector and then I have this linear transformation
of the input which is w transpose x and now this linear transformation is being passed
through this activation function s, okay.
Now there are two ways of thinking about this activation function, okay.
The first is what happens in our neurons, okay.
So what happens in our, in the neurons in our brain is that each neuron receives some
electrical signals, okay, some electrical signals from its input, okay.
And then it does the weighted aggregation of those electrical signals, okay.
And when let us say the signal crosses a particular threshold, this neuron fires, so it also sends
another electrical signal, okay.
So this is the model that our brain performs, okay.
So this particular mechanism of the input activation which is the w, the input, you know
the total input which is w transpose x, it causing a threshold is given by this threshold
function.
So what does the threshold function look like?
So the threshold function, if the input is less than 0, so this is the s function, right.
So s function if the input is less than 0, then the neuron will not fire, so the output
will be 0, okay.
The moment the input crosses 0, the output will be 1, okay.
So this is the threshold function, this is the hard threshold function, okay.
Now this function which is called the stignoid function which is the most commonly used function
is the soft threshold function or the smooth threshold function, okay.
So this is a continuous version of the threshold function and the reason this continuous version
of the threshold function is used is that this function is differentiable, okay.
This will become important when we actually try to derive the back propagation algorithm,
okay.
So this is why the threshold function is not used but instead its approximation the stignoid
function is used, okay.
Now two things to note here, firstly that right now it may seem like that from this diagram
that it is not a very good approximation of the threshold function but actually that is
not the case.
By changing this e to the power minus x, okay, so instead of x if you use e to the power
minus wx what can happen is this slope can change.
So your threshold function can look pretty much like this, so it can look very, very
close to, it can get in fact arbitrarily close to this threshold function.
So using the stignoid function is not really a problem in that sense, okay.
This is the first thing to note.
The second thing to note is that I said that if the input, so here input is w transpose
x, so if the input crosses 0 then only it fires, okay.
But that is not the case because you have another parameter which is b, okay.
So you can tune this b parameter which here I am writing as w0i parameter, okay to actually
move around this, so because you are applying w transpose x plus b here, okay.
The actual aggregation is w transpose x, okay.
So it is fine if w transpose x crosses minus b.
So the actual, so let me just remove this, okay.
So the actual place where this happens, this jump happens, thresholding happens is minus
b and this b is also tunable, okay.
So the position of the threshold is tunable and the, of course the weights are also tunable,
okay.
So in general, this is learning a non-linear transformation which aggregates the input
and then uses a squashing function, okay, okay.
So now these are some of the commonly used activation functions, the sigmoid I have already
talked about, tan hyperbole is very similar to sigmoid.
There is this relu activation function, okay.
It has become much more popular during the deep learning thing and the reason is that
you see the main problem of this sigmoid activation function is it is very, very prone to causing
vanishing or exploding gradients problems, okay, vanishing or exploding gradients problems.
And why is that?
You can see very well, right.
So what is the gradient of this function?
You see in this region the gradient is 0, in this region the gradient is 0, the gradient
is only available in a very small region, okay and that is the reason why it causes
the vanishing or exploding gradient problem more often, okay.
So this relu for example, it has positive or finite gradient in this whole positive
range, okay.
But it still has 0 gradient in the negative range.
So then you can use leaky relu.
So it further reduces the vanishing gradient problem compared to relu, okay.
And this max out is actually nothing but a generalization of relu, okay and so is elu,
okay.
Elu uses little bit of exponential tradeoff or exponential decay in the negative side
and it is like relu in the positive side, okay.
So these are some of the variants that people use, okay.
And the main purpose is to solve this vanishing or exploding gradient problem, okay.
We will see further what this is, okay.
So let me now describe first the perceptron model.
So what is the perceptron model?
Consider two class classification problems.
So what is a two class classification problem?
You have the class plus 1 and you have the class minus 1, okay.
And you have these data points which are vectors.
Right now I am showing them in the two dimensional space, okay.
Now the perceptron, what it does is it computes this.
So if x is the vector it will compute this quantity W transpose x, okay.
If W transpose x is greater than 0 it will predict class 1, okay.
If W transpose x is less than 0 it will predict class minus 1, okay.
So the boundary between the two predictions really is this W transpose x equal to 0, okay.
So let me mathematically state once more.
So the hypothesis function is this f of W transpose x, okay.
Now this is the prediction function as I told you, okay.
Now if you want to write it you can write it as sine of W transpose x.
So this sine function you can think of it as very similar to threshold function except
that in threshold function this output was 0 here it is minus 1, okay.
And this is for computational efficiency nothing else, okay.
So if I called this class as 0 class then it will be the same.
So this is because of if you have seen the SVM derivation or something like that this
is just for notational reason no other reason, okay.
So this sine function is very similar to the threshold function or the step function, okay.
So you can immediately see why this is a neural network, okay.
Why is this a neural network?
Because it is the most simple neural network which has only one neuron.
The neuron takes an input x, okay so this has one neuron.
The neuron takes an input x, x1 till xd let us say are the this is the x vector, okay.
And it has w1 till wd weight, okay and it produces this output y which is the same here
which is the sine of W transpose x, okay.
So this is clearly a neural network this is the simplest form of neural network, okay.
Now at the time that they propose this neural network, okay.
So they had this so they did not have the back propagation and this gradient and here
also you can see since it is a non-differentiable function you cannot actually use a back propagation
algorithm or the gradient descent algorithm to actually learn this, okay.
So instead they use what is called the perceptron learning rule to actually minimize the classification
error and they showed that in case of a linearly separable data set this will actually work,
okay so the perceptron learning rule will actually work, okay.
Now I want you to also understand what is going on here, right.
So this single neuron then is creating a decision boundary which is a linear decision boundary
because W transpose x is equal to 0 is the decision boundary and this is the equation
for a line in a or the actual term is in a higher dimensional plane this is called the
hyper plane, okay.
So this is the equation for a hyper plane, okay and this is in two dimensional plane
you can see that it is a line in three dimensional space it will be a it will be a plane and
in higher dimensional spaces it will be a hyper plane, okay.
Now what is this ZOR problem, okay so the ZOR problem is this particular two class classification
problem, okay so what is the two class classification problem, so the input is two dimensional so
you have x1 or x2 as input, okay.
So here in this particular diagram I am only showing the two input dimensions, okay so
each data point is in two dimensions so this point is 00 this point is 10 this point is
0 or rather this point is 10 so this is 10 this is 01, okay and this point is 11, okay
and this point is 00.
Now what is the output of the ZOR function is when both of them are same that is when
it is 00 or 11 output is 0 otherwise it is 1, okay so that is the ZOR function, okay.
Now you can very easily see that there is no line, okay there is no line which can separate
these two classes, so the classes are output are also 0 and 1 but there is no line in this
two dimensional space which can separate these two classes.
And this is a very simple function, right this is a simple function widely used in many
many cases this ZOR function in fact ZOR function is used to implement addition in electronics
you know, right digital electronics so but this particular function cannot be implemented
and and OR function can be implemented but not this function, okay.
So this was a big setback for a single layer neural network, okay which is something like
a perceptron or a Adalian, okay that was the problem, okay, okay so that led to development
of what is called multilayered perceptron, okay so what is this multilayered perceptron
as you may have imagined it is a neural network, okay where the neurons are arranged in layers,
okay so what do we say, okay so many many so first of all many neurons are organized
into layer, okay this this we have discussed so this is the zeroth layer this is the input,
okay in the box nodes we are showing the input so layer 0 is simply input data, okay.
Then comes neuron taking input from the input data are called layer 1 neuron, okay so these
are the layer 1 neuron, okay what is their property all their inputs are directly connected
to the input data, okay so that is why these are called layer 1 neuron, okay then there
is the layer 2 neuron, so this is the layer 2 neuron, okay layer 2 neuron take all their
input from the output of layer 1 neuron, okay so layer 1 neuron whatever they are computing
that output is being fed into the input of the layer 2 neuron, okay so this is the architecture
of a multi layer perceptron, okay now let us say we denote here as we are denoting by
a so let us say we are denoting by a k, okay the input the input layer, okay so a k is
a vector, okay now if we try to see so I want to compute sorry not a k equal to I want to
compute let us say a j, okay and let us say some particular but neuron so a j is the whole
layer a j is again a vector, okay I want to compute the a j 0 let us say the 0 th entry
so this one is going to be let us say a j and then 0, how will I compute this I will
compute this as summation over w k j, okay and then I will take let us say L, okay the
L th neuron here w k j L, okay multiply it by a k L, okay what is a k a k is the vector
denoting the input, okay and sum over L is equal to 1 to something like d k which is
the number of neurons here d k so what am I doing I am taking the L th neurons input
multiplying by this w k j L, okay and then getting the output, okay so this w k j is
now this metric, okay how do I how do I how many weights do I have for this first layer
for each output neuron I have d k many weights, okay and there are let us say d j many output
neurons in this particular layer so the number of weights in this layer is going to be d j
times d k clear so in each layer the weights are going to be given by a matrix, okay which
is what are the dimensions of this matrix the dimensions of this matrix are number of
input layer number of number of neurons in the input layer, okay times number of neurons
in the output of output layer or number of output neuron yeah output neuron in that particular
layer, okay clear so so similarly here there is only one output so this w j i this is going
to be just 4 weight here there is going to be 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 into 4 so there is
going to be 40 weight, okay so there is going to be 10 cross 4 matrix in this particular
layer and this is going to be just a 4 cross 1 matrix, okay and this is the computation
of course there is going to be a activation function here, okay so this is how the computation
proceeds so it is very important to understand how the computation for a multi-layer perceptron
proceeds, okay so in particular layer n takes input from layer 0 to layer n minus 1 neuron,
okay so remember this, okay that if it can also happen that this neuron gives input to
here, okay so this kind of a input is also possible but that will not be called a multi-layer
perceptron that will be some other architecture, okay so that is a valid neural network architecture
but it will become a different neural network architecture, okay another thing also important
thing see here every neuron in the input of a particular layer is connected to every other
neuron in the output you can see this neuron is connected to this connected to this connected
to this and connected to this, okay so this kind of a connection is another thing in multi-layer
perceptron or fully connected network, okay so sometimes you will see this the layer in
a multi-layer perceptron is also called fully connected layer, okay so in when you write
programs you will see that what you are using is fully connected layer, okay so this is
about neural networks, okay so this further you know makes that particular computation
that I just showed clearer, okay so you can see here like G is the activation function
for each of the neurons, two input neurons are there input neurons are called I think
a1 and a2, okay so what you are doing is you are multiplying this w13 times a1 and w23
times a2 so w13 times a1 and w23 times a2 to get this particular let us call this a3,
okay so you get this a3 like this and so on and so forth, okay, okay so what is the hidden
layer here, okay so in any neural network all the layers which are not input or output
layer are called hidden layer, why are they called hidden layer because when you are actually
doing the computation these will remain inside the neural network as a person using the neural
network you will never see the output of these, okay so that is why these are called hidden
layer, okay so you will only give the input which is x and then in between there will
be lots of hidden layers and then there will be some output which is y, the way you think
about a neural network is y is equal to f of x, okay in between how many layers are
there that you when you are designing the neural networks you will use it but as a user
of the neural network you need not bother about this that is why these are called the
hidden layers of the neural network, okay so the question is can we solve the new how
many hidden layers do we need and what kind of hidden layers do we need, okay so that
is one of the main questions as a neural network designer what you have to answer is how many
hidden layer and what kind of hidden layer, okay so here is one architecture for solving
the ZOR problem so you know that ZOR problem a single layer cannot solve, okay so the question
is how can we solve the ZOR problem and here is a solution so the solution is that you
use one single hidden layer, okay and in this hidden layer you have only two neurons h1
and h2, okay now what is the formula for h1 h1 is simply so you know that x1 and x2 are
binary here so x1 and x2 they all belong to this set 0 comma 1, okay now you simply say
20 x1 plus 20 x2 minus 10 what is this going to do so when both x1 and x2 are 0 this input
will be negative so this will be negative, okay but when both x1 and x2 are positive
it will be positive so these two will be positive, okay with h1 and similarly this one will also
be positive, okay so for h1 it will basically implement this yellow line can you see that
this one will be negative and all the other data points will be positive, okay so this
is the first one that h1 is implementing this yellow line of classification, okay now what
about h2, okay so h2 is minus 20 x1 minus 20 x2 plus 30, okay so opposite of what h1
was doing so when it is 0, 0 this is plus 30 so this will be positive, okay now if one
of x1 and x2 is 0 so if it is 1, 0 or 0, 1 these two will also be positive, okay but
this one will be negative, okay so it is implementing this blue line, okay now in the output layer
there is one more neuron here what is this neuron doing, this neuron is simply 20 times
h1 plus 20 times h2 minus 30, okay so what this will do, okay this is simply you can
say in one way of thinking about it is it is simply adding h1 and h2, okay so what this
does for this one and then it is subtracting 30 from that, okay so for this one both h1
and h2 were, sorry h1 was outputting negative but h2 was outputting positive, okay so this
sum is going to be 0, okay or like sum minus 30 is going to be 0 so h1 is actually going
to be h1 is going to be 0 and h2 is going to be 1, okay in the other case for this one
also same thing but the other way around h1 is going to be outputting 1 and h2 is going
to be outputting 0 in both these cases the overall output will be 0, okay only if both
h1 and h2 are outputting 1 then the output will be 1 and that is for these two points,
for these two points if you remember for these two points the green point both h1 and h2
are outputting 1, okay so this is one design of a neural network, okay for solving the
Zord problem here note that when we say design of a neural network we have manually substituted
W's and B's, right so we have manually shown what is W and B's in practice you simply
have to say what these connections will be the learning of the actual parameter will
be done by the learning algorithm, okay so this is just to demonstrate what kind of thought
process goes behind designing this neural network which is the question for multi layer
perceptron is how many hidden layers and what is the number of neurons in each hidden layer,
okay, okay now let me formalize so this is the key idea behind a neural network so what
I just demonstrated is the key idea behind the neural network, okay so okay so maybe
I will take a 5 minute break, okay and we will come back with this idea how to design
this neural network what is the thought process behind design of neural network, okay thank